okay at what point are you guys like wow
she's pregnant what are we gonna do and
how do you hide that from the world well
you know I mean she she was she was very
careful about who knew and we only knew
really the very very kind of latest
stages
um so you know her and her team
carefully managed that and we obviously
also then carefully uh manage that
because it's you know it's a it's a very
very big deal isn't it and it's a very
very personal joyous moment so it's for
her to tell the world
um you know you know so not only were we
obviously very mindful of the fact that
she was pregnant but we're also very
mindful of this kind of a show hasn't
been done before either so there were so
many secrets and so many Mysteries that
had to be kept you know that's what I
want to ask you about how did you keep
all those things so secret the little
things from getting out because that's a
lot of moving pieces you you know what I
mean some of the secrets were more
easily kept than others and I honestly
don't know how I honestly don't know how
that whole concept didn't get out
because you know we were rehearsing in
the stadium it was people walking around
obviously cell phone usage was very
strictly monitored there was a huge
amount of respect for the Endeavor that
we were taking and I think people were
like you know what fair play to them you
know I I'm I'm maybe in the stadium I'm
maybe working in this Stadium but I'm
not going to ruin it for America I'm not
going to ruin it for all these people
who are working really really hard to
keep it a secret and to keep it a
surprise so I think given the ambition
of the idea the kind of the lunacy
almost in some ways of the idea I think
anybody who was going to kind of tell
the world was like you know what
let me keep the secret let me let me let
me let me be good wow
how scary was it with those platforms
because you're putting a pregnant woman
60 feet in the air how scary was it as
you watch her go up and down and move
around
I mean you know for me it wasn't super
scary but for her I'm sure it was really
scary because I mean you know she's not
fond of heights either so for her it was
like super brave and you know we
practiced it in baby steps you know
first it was 10 feet then it was 20 then
it was 30. we were in the crypto theater
in
um in Los Angeles you went up to 30 feet
and then the stadium 40 50 60. you know
it was it was a process but she got
there and fair player you know I mean
really all credit to her wow so you guys
practiced it in crypto took your time
and worked with those all those things
all those those floating stages yeah the
floating platforms I mean again you know
technically a real Masterpiece not been
done before really ambitious and you
know that would be brave thing to do in
like a Broadway show where you've got
months and months to set it up and
months and months to kind of set it you
know this is a Super Bowl I mean eight
minutes to get all that stuff out check
it safety check it make sure it's cool
deploy it and then fly her up with her
ears in ready to go it's like I mean it
was ridiculously I mean ridiculously
ambitious was there a moment in
rehearsals because she's 60 feet up in
the end when did you finally get up to
60 feet and how comfortable there were
so many times when I thought this is not
going to happen so so many times you
know the cameras didn't work the
platform stopped
um you know it was just it was it was a
really ambitious thing to do but
platforms stopping the safeties you know
there were lots of kind of like you know
lots of times when safety was was
engaged and we had to stop reassess you
know there were never any times when we
were put anybody in danger but there
were a lot of times when you know we
need to stop evaluate the safety and
then carry on and you know it's it's
when you've got someone 60 feet in the
air and a tiny little postage stamp
you've got to be really careful and
you've got to go slow and the Super Bowl
isn't going about going the slow the
Super Bowl Halftime is about going fast
being ambitious but going fast and
safety isn't fast so all of that thing
all of those processes had to get
married and you know thankfully it all
went so so well and when when that
opening shot happened I was like yeah
because I knew I knew once one was down
all the kind of the computer technology
would kick in and it was highly likely
that we would get to the end you know
[Music]